how Ai and the gener AI is the
revolutionizing disease diagnosis
including rare diseases I'm Andrea doen
I'm a data scientist and I lead the a ml
Automation and a gen for the AI
automation at IBM Consulting so here are
my teammates
summer hello everyone my name is Sumer J
and U I'm currently a senior data
scientist for also from IBM Consulting
um I'm based here at New York City
office yeah my name is Theos jaos senior
data scientist I in New
York thank
you so here is our talk agenda we will
start with the excitement of the of
leveraging AI in medical imaging
diagnosis and the associated challenges
and we are going to share our Solutions
approaches and after that we are going
to cover two demos one is image to image
generation the other one is text to
image
generation and after that we will share
our point of view on the important steps
that need to be taken before clinical
implementation and our talk will take
about 30
minutes and we will have a Q&A session
at the
end okay so without a doubt uh
artificial intelligence is the
most discussed topic today in medical
image area and uh AI has advantage of
uncovering disease characteristics that
human eyes cannot catch so this includes
different Imaging image um modalities
like CT M ultrasound graphy
Etc and the different tasks like tumor
detection
segmentation and the disease prediction
and the new era of AI combining the Gena
Ai and the traditional AI have so far
demonstrated very promising
Improvement so the potential
applications are vast but similar to
human learning deep learning also need
to learn from numerous amount of image
examples so medical medical image
analysis also requires Medical Imaging
data set so that process includes the
entirely of a medical imaging life cycle
from image creation to diagnosis to
outcome
prediction however
currently researchers have been
described as data
star
why so the first obstacle here is the
data
privacy and patient related hair
information was protected by tight
privacy
policies and making a clinical medical
image available for research require
regulatory
approval it also limits cross
institution image sharing so that's why
relevant images are usually in high
demand and the short
supply the Second Challenge here is the
image
quality the way each clinical practice
is the way each clinic clinic practices
is different the quality of the data
generation from different practices can
be very different too
and if we can overcome these challenges
the cost saving that AI can bring is
very significant it is estimated that AI
applications can cut annual us healthare
cost by 115 billion in
2026 but how can we overcome these
barriers we believe that synthetic data
synthetic image data specifically can be
one of the solutions
synthetic image
data is artificially generated image
data as opposed to data collected from
real
events which mimics real word patterns
to represent High Fidelity to
reality you can see the top five Advance
uh Advantage here of the synthetic image
data it protects patient
privacy because it reduce the needs of a
real patient
data and the second it provides large
amount of a diverse training data that
are crucial for building robust and
reliable AI
models so the diagnostic model accuracy
can get
improved with the more synthetically
generated training data
set and the synthetical image data can
be generated at the lower cost compared
to real data it can reduce the time and
the cost of a challenging real world
medical image
data the the uh it can reduce the time
and the cost of collecting the real data
so this allows us to save time and money
while still being able to train the
diagnostic model
effectively so now I'm going to turn the
state to Summer to talk about the
technical details and showcase the demo
that we prepared for the audience
here thank you so much Andrea and now
moving on um first I would like to say
that um you know like since Andrea
mentions lots of like benefits and
importance of synthetic images and how
it came to play for medical diagnosis we
do want to dive deeper into the demos
here so basically we will introduce the
two types of models and we'll be showing
two ex um and since all of those methods
are not only applicable to the medical
uh diagnosis area but are also
applicable to other domains as well so
start thinking about your own generative
task from today um the first type of
model we want to mention is uh image to
image model the second is text to image
model basically the first one is those
generative models that will learn the
mapping like use a real image as the
input during the training phase and they
will use um they will learn the mapping
uh phases uh during the training process
so to reproduce this new variation um as
close as the uh real image um for and to
generate the synthetic data some popular
models include JN models V model and
diffusion models due to the limitation
of time today uh we won't go into
details for the previous two but
diffusion model is probably one of the
most popular models going on in all the
domains uh we'll be covering a a demo
today for the latent diffusion model and
it's both applicable to 2D and 3D image
generation the second type is the text
to image models basically it gave you a
chat GPT like um experience uh we use
both text and image as the input for the
training phase and then we will use the
natural language prompt to ask the model
to generate um one image for us um
pretty easy right um some popular models
is like uh stable diffusion this one was
published by stability AI completely
open source you can access it via
hugging phase um you can also fine-tune
it and we will be demoing it today also
we got Del 3 this one was uh recently
released um I think earlier last Mouse
by open Ai and it's now available in
chat
jp4 um also we got meat Journey this one
is mainly for artistic image generation
but we are starting to see his
application in other domains as well so
now moving on to the first demo belongs
to the image to image generation
category basically we will be leveraging
latent diffusion model to generate 2D
chass x-ray images with plural diffusion
we came up with this idea because um
plural Fusion is one of the most common
lung disease and it's affecting 1.5
million Americans every single year
however um you know like for some
Downstream task like classifications or
if you want to build some diagnosis
assistant um it requires a very tedious
and tiring image collection process um
so that we come up with this solution to
use a open source data set it's called
um mad Mist uh and it contains uh
different types of 2D and 3D images
including chass a with plur diffusion
and we use it to train our own latent
diffusion model and afterwards we
actually uh compare lots of other
state-ofthe-art models as well and turns
out latent diffusion model was um
outperform all of it with the lowest
validation loss which was based on MS e
uh and uh on the right hand side there
are some sample images the first three
are like our sample input uh for the
training process and uh the on the right
hand side are like the sample synthetic
image that was being generated and now
we will go to the notebook to um show
you how we make the whole generation
process
work um yeah let me know if this this
phone size is okay um so basically first
uh we want to give credit to the open
source framework monai we used for those
of you who are not familiar with monai
this is a completely open-source free
available collaborative uh framework
that's buil specifically for medical
imaging it's build upon pound pie torch
and it's um giving you lots of like
because for medical image one of the
difficulties like to read the image
since they are of very high resolution
and some of it uh like requires like
dcom or some special type of um image
image type that requires lots of
different software to use so this is a
really uh this software is super helpful
so we want to give credit to it and then
for I'm not sure if everybody here is
familiar with the latent diffusion model
because be before I started this project
I was not at all familiar with it so I
just want to use one minute to quickly
share with you how it worked and don't
worry if you don't follow because we
will be showing this graph for multiple
times afterwards so basically we got the
real image X and we will put it into an
auto encoder to generate it latent
representation in this lower Dimension
dimensional space and then coming to the
diffusion process basically we are
adding random noise to this uh generated
feature this lower dimensional features
to get uh DT which is a noise feature
and then we will train this we will put
this uh DT this noise feature as the
input for the den noising unit to be
trained to iterate for T times which the
unit will learn how to predict and does
to remove the noise in each of the
iteration uh during which we will also
have this conditioning layer which you
will be applying other conditions as
well to make sure you are getting the
image you want and afterwards you will
get this uh reconstructed feature D and
we will put it back to the pixel Space
by using the decoder to get the
synthetic image so that's how it work
pretty easy right um so now let's um set
up the environment uh imported lots of
um functionality from monai and also
torch um then we like to uh get all the
data ready we first um get this we got
all the image from the madm data set
this is also like a publicly available
medical image data set it contains you
can see different type of data like hand
or hat CT or breast MRI different kind
of 2D and 3D images but for to work for
our end goal which is for um chass x
with plural Fusion we only use this
particular type of um image here and we
are visualizing it to make sure we are
getting the right images then we set up
our validation data set as well so that
once we get everything ready we will
first Define the auto encoder here in
the r box which we've covered before um
this Auto encoder comes with this kl
regularization to make sure it's it was
transformed into this latent
representation while also it's it the
distribution is still accordance with in
in accordance with goian
distribution um basically to do that we
need to initialize this Auto encoder KL
and we will specify the perceptual loss
um the adverse loss and also the
optimizer and then we train this Auto
encoder you probably need to change the
eort here based on your computational
resource um I was actually training it
on my local machine it was pretty quick
very impressive but if you have like a
higher computational resource probably
you should change it to like 100 or 200
um yeah and we can see the result here
once it's everything finished um you can
see the reckon loss is decreasing looks
good and we can visualize um all the
intermediary images and also like the
like what's the latent um representation
being
generated after that is done we will
move on to the diffusion model which is
the large green box here um to begin
with we want to get all the parts ready
um um like the first important component
is um the diffusion process basically
it's here we want to add random noise to
the latent variable Z so we add noise we
will iterate it and the second component
is um inside this latent space we also
want to get the unit setup ready and
also all the
schedulers so here we want to to um we
want to set up the unit and uh also
getting the scaling Factor this also
make sure the signal to noise Ral
doesn't uh deviate too much from a gsan
distribution and we have our schedule
ready we got uh we wrap it up into this
infer and thus we can start this whole
training process basically it works as
follows we use the auto encoder to get
the Z which is the latent representation
with then add noise you need to
fine-tune the time stamps here and then
the model will predict the noise in
instead of the actual pictures um so
yeah we do so for both to get the
training loss and validation
lws after all the epoch finished um we
can plot the learning curve to see okay
the loss is constantly decreasing and uh
last but not least we want to bring back
to the pixel play so that we can get our
synthetic image which is our angle right
so we decode the image and uh I want to
show you guys how the noise is being
removed gradually so I wrap it
everything up in this function so it can
show you like at first it was like a
random noise and then the unit is
iterate so it gradually remove the noise
and then you got this s
image well so basically that you can
change the function a little bit so that
it will only give you the synthetic
image instead of all the intermed
intermediary steps but that's how it
work and now I will pass it on to my
colleague SE to talk about the text to
image
generation yeah thank you so much for
that wonderful presentation um as ear
mentioned you will agree with me that
most of the problem we face in the field
of computer vision is lack
of the area of dat argumentation and
annotation and in general many people
have faced this issue because of privacy
concerns earlier mentioned so we now we
came up with the idea of okay how can we
live stable diffusion model or other P
model maybe in the hugy face or in the
stable diffusion as well so that we can
generate more images you can use to
train your model so going with that we
start by you know using the same data
said from the M list we work on the
pneumonia because if you watch very well
most of the people not just only in
America across the world there issue be
people suffering for the case of
pneumonia over they were killing large
number of people so can what what can we
do to be able to H mitigate this effect
we leverage on this model to be able to
do that and you will when talking about
stable diffusion and Testo image it has
two M components where whereby you send
your image to the model en code that
image to the lat space then you give a
test pront uh to that image then you not
do a kind of coine similarity
computation where by do the do to know
how similar the image is then you can
retrieve that same image from from the
um train model from here you can see
from here this is the real image this
one here is the real image we get from
the we use in training our model then
when we print a the model okay generate
image of a pneumonia which you can also
apply to your personal use case maybe
you in advertisement or anything you
want to do you have a clo or anything
just use it to train your mod then when
you give a test point you will learn
from that distribution of that your
image or whatever you ske you want to
work on then can give you that same
image back then if you check very well
one of the image is a front image I gave
which is the first one here to give me a
test rather yeah a test PR to give me an
image without pneumonia then I feed it
back to this um pre-train model I did
the classifier which is this particular
one to really check if the synthetic
image generated is really in
confirmation with what I really want and
the mod was able to classify that yes is
really a normal image I also did the
same thing for the case of a pneumonia I
give a test Point give me image of a
pneumonia image then I have that I also
check and I was able to the was able to
check uh give us a case Okay is really a
pneumonia just to validate the test uh
synthetic image you are generating if
really what the mod or the classify or
whatever train you want to do so going
back to the um to The
Notebook like I said before we leverage
on the stable defici model at this point
uh which I already explain here that the
reason why we need stable diffusion and
all of
that then we install our dependency for
here I just check the my GPU because
training a stable diffusion like with
your images it really take a lot of
times so you have to know you have the
enough capacity uh capacity and all of
that to do that in terms of your device
then I load it from my drive in you know
where you get your data you can load it
from there from here um yeah you when
because of the M I'm using uh petray mod
is really from the huging face interface
so you have you have to ensure that you
you're able to log into the hugging face
then that's why I did this then from
here I set up the parameters like the
Precision recall and all of that that we
be able to know the performance of your
mod at this point I lo the data
set from yeah the data then we have a
class of a case of pneumonia and non
pneumonia at this point you can see from
here at this here we just do some
transformation like in case maybe you
flip the image
like Z to pneumonia ponia to Z this kind
of stuff you know in terms of La images
here I Define the this is the petray
model I use from the huging F you know
already yeah then I defin the data set
where I'm going to be getting my data
set from which is this particular place
then this is the my the name of the mod
I gave which is the test to image P data
2023 so I specified thetic parameter I'm
going to use you can really find this in
the h face interface and how you can
train your model one thing you should
not here is that when training you you
must be able to set uh to specify your
parameter correctly like your image must
be 512 by 512 otherwise this will
fail then that was the case of
generative image then I build a
classifier leverage of the same model
then from here we do the image
transformation then compute the Define a
function to compute the metrix then we
keep do the training parameter here the
train is start you know we did the
training then the validation L as you
can see it reduced drastically as as the
training loss from here you can see from
the graph how the validation and the
training laws reduced from the from the
during the training now look at the
confusion mry here but when you can see
fully well that he was able to perform
well in terms of generating a pneumonia
image same with the number but it
misclassify in terms of some number so
which also subject to further training
or image then at this point this is
where I write a function to do the
generation so when I okay generate chest
exray image with pneumonia then I
specifi the number you want 10 20 100 or
whatever at this point now you not you
can get maybe thousands of images of the
kind of test you want then this is where
we get from the um for the synthetic
image you can see very well that is
exactly the same um original image but
one thing you should note here is that
when giving a test the pront here is
very important you know sometimes
because they in the same latent space it
can generate the same image for you so
he learn from those parameters and all
of that so that is
it from those synthetic image we give
you DET like I said before thank you so
much
yeah so now you've seen the demos of
image to image and the text to image
Generation Um and here are the pros and
the cons of each approach um based on
our experience so with the image to
image model the um is a proficient in
generating both 2D and 3D images and we
have a more control over the parameter
tuning and the Fidelity of the output of
the image is relatively higher and
however the technical expertise around
tuning the parameters are required and
the
interpretability um is a little bit low
meaning that it's hard to explain to
non-technical people how to um transform
from how to generate image based out of
image and with the Tex to image is
required different set of domain expse
we need to learn how to best the tumor
prompt right um and the legal ethical
concerns come with with it and how to
make Ai and a gen AI more trustworthy is
a Hot Topic right now an important topic
and it's specifically how we make sure
the output doesn't have a bias um no
toxicity and no personal
information and lastly we cannot use
this approach to generate the three the
imag
yet before the image medical image the
before the synth medical image can be
used for the development of a AI
algorithm certain steps need to be taken
and first is the data appropriation
right we need a approval um of the use
of the medical image due to privacy
concerns and after iCal approval we need
to standardize it right the data from
different organizations and how to make
the standardize and have them share the
images and after that we want to
identify the personal information and go
through quality
control and uh have the labeled right so
then that's data appropriation the next
one is the disease
diagnosis that's the angle of gener in
this synthetic data is to create enough
training data set that can be used for
the diagnostic model right to make that
model more
accurate and this is a downam task that
we did not cover
today um and last but not least we need
a medical professionals input and we
need their guidance in this process
medical expertise will help us to
better create the wrong choose for the
training data set it also provides the
accurate more accurate diagnosis inter
interpretation so here is the last slide
this summarize the end to end life cycle
from Med image generation to diagnosis
and to outcome
prediction and the input can be image or
can be a prompt and the it goes through
different models to generate syct data
as we demoed and that things data need
to be validated by clinical
professionals before they are qualified
to be used for the diagnostic
model and to conclude today's talk the
new eror of AI combining traditional Ai
and genifer AI has shown promising
Advantage advantage
in this research field and with the
current success of AI in image research
we anticipate that it will continue play
a dominant
role and uh our team um is dedicated to
making contribution in this exciting
field and we look forward to further the
development and The
Innovation thank you very
[Applause]
much